[Music]
in spicy Science News spicy Science
spance Boston submitted by I love JK so
much thank you that you're willing to
eat a
booger do it a Yale Professor explains
how eating spicy foods will help keep
you cool this summer what that sounds
like an Asian thing it is sell Asian cuz
you know on a hot day they tell you to
eat hot food like temperature hot or
spicy so it doesn't feel so hot anymore
Oh I thought it was because this is I
feel like I read this when you eat spicy
food it produces sweat and then and then
that cools you down I mean that's the
science explanation but the Asian
explanation is like the temperature is
hotter there just make your temperature
hotter so then when the outside feels
cooler yes it burn from the inside so
the outside you eat spicy ass food
because Thai Spice is like [__] burn
spice I eat spicy ass food yeah you
could drink Sriracha probably huh I I
enjoy a lot of sriracha yeah well not
too much cuz s Sriracha is a really
powerful flavor sometimes it's a little
overpowering but I I can eat some spicy
[__] yeah I could eat spicy food but
spicy food don't like me that's my CU
Tha chili It's not like ooh that's a
little bit of flaming hot Cheeto it's
like ah my taste buds can't taste my dad
always says that uh Tha dicks are like
Thai chilies they're not big but they're
the most powerful all right how cute but
there's definitely most cute what's
what's dangerous is there's definitely
the green Thai chilies when they're in
soup they look like just a buz a piece
of [__] like broccoli or something
yes so when you're eating like tomyam or
like you yeah you'll bite right into it
it'll make your whole [__] go
numb it's so [__] annoying like why
are you in there like don't be in there
yeah one of my favorite places is called
pot or noodle out in Hollywood [__] that
place cuz they always put the that [__]
next to the same thing you don't put
them in the same dish why don't they
just rain the juice out and then throw
the [__] thing away you don't have to
get confused with it I always get mild
now cuz I got medium and I almost yacked
cuz it was medium is like hot yeah spicy
hot and they [__] find if they're all
laughing so funny
like [__] [__] he can't pick a
spice look at the little beach I know
cuz they have that's the difference
between Asian restaurants is like
they'll [__] laugh in your face oh
it's too spicy for you instead of like
oh I'm so sorry let me get you another
thing oh you can't take the spice you
little [__] it's like dude what the I'm
a customer you
[__] [__] too spicy oh it's some T food
now some [__] boat noodle sound that
does sound bomb we got to go to thay
it's rest in peace you guys close down
the rest you didn't know it's weird I
never got to eat it before they you
didn't know his parents retired Ty smile
retired in I want to say beginning of
2016 oh [__] that's a year ago man yeah
year and a half yeah they retired they
sold it yeah I wish I knew that because
you guys made like the dumplings with
gravy on that [__] that's what you guys
ordered the first time we met up I know
and they don't have they don't have that
they don't have that at anywhere what is
that it's just their own creation it's
like it was super random you know how
they do the the bird's nest [__] it was
like lat na but poured over some like
wanton so it's like the gravy on top of
the so imagine like the the the
dumplings right the deep fried dumplings
yeah the golden bags yeah but then the
one in triangles not the not the go
style but the ones in triangles and then
you throw on that [__] Chow [__] that
gravy can they uh take over the
restaurant again just for like a
month or do they still make the same
kind of food at home no actually the
people that took over the restaurant
they're selling it cuz the business was
so trash after they took over they're
selling it again to someone else see you
can't replicate the food is the problem
Dan was your parents cooking it yeah my
mom's if my mom wasn't cooking it was
her recipes yeah oh see that's what
happened see people no when when wheny
customers know they know when the food
is different they
know they know they know they know they
know you guys should come over for
dinner like my mom my mom still cook
I'll bring a I'll bring a whole bunch of
hesy dude never [__] get the text
literally um I want the won thing the
other homies that were used to eating in
my at my restaurant um they're like dude
we like Benji was like I miss your mom's
food bro from the restaurant and my mom
was like have them come over and then
and then it turned from like two people
to like five people just over for dinner
yeah come through oh [__] dinner at Tims
that's dope I'm down yeah so you guys uh
hit it spot on with this yell Professor
was saying about
spiciness what I totally forgot about I
have to remind you guys yeah so what
he's saying is that the chemical
capsacin that's in all the these chilies
that oh capsacin I used to have those
after school in little pouches really
that's a cap free
Styles I was like what what are you
talking about t people really do like
spice I know that's what I was thinking
like maybe it's a tie thing I don't know
so what they're saying is that it
produces heat in your body which then
makes you sweat and the sweat is
supposed to cool you down so that's why
they're saying spicy food when you're
hot eating spicy food when you're hot is
good for you and so they're also saying
that there's this reaction no go ahead
go ahead I'm not going to talk to you
what you're actually not interrupting
I'm going let you I'm going to let you
finish thank you Joe yeah so he's not
going to let you finish knew someone
else is going to Dr No but you know it's
crazy so you know how a lot of people
it's really hard like certain people
it's hard to eat spicy food after a long
time of you not eating spicy food yep so
there's this uh neurotransmitter called
substance p and P is for pain and so
they're saying that pretty much it'll be
depleted slowly over time if you don't
like continue I knew interesting so even
though you can't eat spicy food like
it's really hard for people to eat spicy
food if you slowly train yourself it it
has nothing to do with the pain in my
mouth pain in the ass is the thing I
have a problem with you need a substance
pee in your butthole yep exactly that
doesn't work though it just feels like
I'm [__] a
dragon like when it comes did you guys
have that when you were younger I didn't
have that when I was younger cuz when I
was younger especially high school I
love the spiciest [__] we would have
spicy challenges I would go to
restaurants give me the spiciest stuff
and I built that tolerance right and
then for some reason I just had no
interest in eating spicy stuff and
collagen on and then when I got back to
it I can't take it no more I know it's
going to happen too your pe's gone bro y
so my question is yes eating spicy stuff
is it it helps you out in the hot times
right but what about the ulcers and what
about the stomach problems yeah you got
to think about that and what about the
fact that when you're hot you sweat
anyway so what's the point of eating
that's true too there you there it is
right there [__] this professor you
dumbass well well here's the thing
though for someone like me you know me I
don't really sweat you know what I'm
saying so sweat I don't it takes a lot
to get me sweaty yeah like I've been
sitting next to him in a in a in a SAA
before and he was been like why AR you
[__] sweating you don't even sweat in
a sauna it takes me a while how about
how about when you work out like um I
really I don't really work out but wait
when you go continuously cuz I remember
I didn't used to sweat a lot until I
started working out a lot I have to do
like a lot of cardio to get sweaty like
a lot this [__] sweats for no
reason you drink a lot of water I
sweating I do I do um so I was going to
say for me since I uh I don't sweat
automatically from heat it might be good
for me you know what I'm saying cuz the
spicy [__] spiciness sometimes it has to
be really spicy too you know like that
Ramen challenge [__] yo [__] that thing
too man that [__] is hella spicy my
brother could take spicy food cuz he
after I showed him it I was like do you
want to try it he goes dude this is Bomb
he bought a pack and he just ate the
whole thing for pleasure yeah that one
wasn't that spicy actually the regular
one was was fine there's the the next
level one two times kind of crazy my dad
my brother just eats that [__] for the
[__] of it I almost died on the the one
time I [__] almost done you know can
you take spice no I I can't handle spice
to save my life spicy spicy it it
started getting black like I was getting
a tunnel by the end of what happened to
me when we did the chili pepper thing
for J party I started seeing like black
spots oh [__] I'm going to pass what for
real you know what really [__] up my
stomach though those [__] late night
tacos because I know for a fact those
are delicious I know but I put too much
salsa on it you got to kill the bacteria
you have to cuz I always put extra salsa
cuz I like the taste of it but I know
it's going to hurt my stomach the next
day and I just wait I'm like tomorrow
morning it's going to happen I wake up
and blow like 17 punches right into my
intestine blow blow blow and I'm like
you know what's crazy now you just made
me realize um cuz you know I guess you
know you sweat and then it feels good
when when it's hot right that's what
they're saying in this article and so my
[__] also hurts when I eat spicy food
food but when I wipe and wash my ass
it's like ah man it feels great yeah the
relief feels good yeah but see there's
that oil that stays around there so like
the after I [__] like the next 10
minutes it hurts it feels chafed yeah so
so I'm walking all oh but I get in the
tub right away and wash my ass I chill
in there yeah after after I take a
really SP I should get up a day because
when I have spicy shits like that I do
the enema part so that [__] shoots
water up your [__] right and it fills
up your int it's like a balloon wait up
your [__] you get it right on there
you get it inside what Happ it has to be
a certain feature in the bday it's
called bortex it's called called Vortex
I did it to myself accidentally but then
this other time when I started having
when I had uh diarrhea I said to myself
hey I got few pieces left in there but
it's not coming out I need to Vortex it
and then what the vortex did is shot
Water up there made it into a balloon
and it was
like yeah yeah that makes sense that
makesense it pushed out the rest and I
felt clean so it's it's like if you have
if you have [__] chili seeds in your
intestines and it's not coming out use
the vort vortex it's going to shoot
those chili seeds out and you're going
to feel like a new man yeah cuz it's at
the office and that [__] when I thought
that was the only way to use the bedet
and so when we both Ed it like that not
at the same time but when we used it
it's like you can't even stop it it just
cut it just it's just get the [__] out
the way and it just goes right in wait
the tube doesn't go up your [__] the
water pressure so hard y probably
should forces it
so water pressure how do you not jump I
screamed I said no it just went in
anyway oh my God it didn't listen to you
[__] ass imagine you're puckering
your lips as hard as possible but
somehow that water gun is going through
your [__] mouth my boy
Tex I I tried I tried to resist I was
like oh what the [__] and it was like on
full power too somebody [__] pranked
it oh my God somebody pranked
it it's like Terry Cruz in Friday after
next when he [__] uh took down what's
his name Cat Williams right and he just
took it that's exactly what it is hope
you guys enjoyed that video but if you
didn't guess what you can directly
contribute to the articles that we
discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click right up
here
n